hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video Rebecca I'm Borderlands three
again and we're gonna be talking about a
new patch that is gonna be going live
today it's a small house but it does
have a very unique change especially for
you Amara players so you this can all be
found on the borderlands website I'll
leave a link to it down in the
description if you want to look at it
for yourself later in the future and
right now there's also a little bit of
gameplay of the newest DLC coming to the
game of the amok C's heist but we had
already seen that if you watch the
borderland show but if you do want to
see that you totally check it out on the
website but we're really here for the
hotfix today so we're just gonna be
going by and scrolling through and
seeing what we can look at from this
little blog post so it says that this is
going to roughly be going live by 3:00
p.m. PST so 6:00 p.m. for you boys in
the east like myself and this is going
to be getting rid of the bloody harvest
event it's going to be getting rid of
the Haunted enemies the traveling to
heck and all of the challenges are going
to be gone up until next year and I also
believe that that means we won't be able
to get any terror annointed weapons but
I am maybe a little bit wrong on that
statement they also had they also
addressed a couple issues about one
being where the loot would fall if they
ruin the map in the slaughter star 3000
and then they also have a reported issue
where the movement speed bonus with
Amara's passive ability mindfulness when
buff with the spiritual driver class mod
was sometimes extremely high if you have
played with anybody in-game or anything
like that in regards to the malla wanna
take down then you are totally aware
that american solo this on mayhem 4 with
this type of build using multiple
variations of cuts means so this looks
like it's going to be a little bit of an
issue for Amara players says right here
that mindfulness was designed with the
intent that reaching maximum stacks was
not easily achievable so the bonus per
grade was high we want players to take
advantage of move speed but not to the
extent where parts of the game may not
function correctly there was also an
issue with the spiritual driver class
mod where it would award some times of
basically rewarding all types of damage
and not just gun damage so I'm assuming
just from these stats of what they're
explaining that they're probably going
to dumb down the speed of the class mod
as well as get rid of the extra damage
and just do the gun damage and maybe
even nerf it so that when you happen to
do phase grass but doesn't
should we count you have to phase grasp
a specific enemy and not just do it at
the floor but well that remains to be
seen that's off of that day decrease the
pet audio for flexor Jabbar Zane's
passive ability death follows close
fails to bring correct bonus to several
kill skills unlocking this ability in
the skills menu also another thing would
Zayn nerves of steel which would
sometimes lose its functionality after
fast travelling fixing typos on
desperate measures and stainless steel
bare skills multiple spots where players
were able to escape the map and sky well
multiple spots where people would get
stuck in amber mine and a bunch of other
small things like not hearing the
flaming skulls with Billy and other
things that are while they are issues
and bug fixes I feel like these top two
things that we explained are definitely
a lot more important than the stuff at
the bottom they said the hot fixes
generally addressed smaller things while
patches contain code that must go
through a lengthier patch process the
next patch will be coming later this
month and will contain the first DLC
which is Moxie's highest of the handsome
jackpot it will also address reporter
concerns that we have seen in the last
patch regarding Guardian rank additional
banging machines in sky wall 27 and a
couple other things as well so
definitely on the lookout for that and
also for you people just like myself who
can't beat the metal on black site
takedown for [ __ ] there's going to be in
a limited time event the takedown at the
Mallo on black site will be scaled
depending on the number of players in
your party you'll be able to play solo
or with a party of any size and score
that's weak takedown loot so we can
finally play this thing solo and not
have to rely on our teammates and not
get smacked so at the end of this month
of course it is December so towards the
end of the year as well there is going
to be this going live so if you're a
solo player like myself rejoice because
we can finally get that take down loot
because I still haven't beat it yet yeah
let me know what you guys think about
this stuff in the comments below it's a
little bit intriguing to kind of you
know figure out that Amara's finally
getting some different types of patches
other than just maybe a small bug fix
and she's finally getting tuned up
although it might not be in the way that
people had expected she is a very very
powerful vault hunter she's probably the
most powerful at the moment from all the
nerfs that the other three have been
receiving and you know zane slowly
trying to get up there with all of his
buffs amara is definitely one of the
more
popular ones as well then I've been
noticing besides flack but we'll see how
this goes I think it'll still make a
Barra very popular I think she'll still
be able to take down the malla one
takedown event and still do it solo just
maybe not as good as everybody is going
to expect it will be but we'll see how
the patch goes cuz currently at the
moment as I'm making this video it isn't
even live yet so we'll have to see how
that goes
even though my notes you guys think
about the stuff in the comments below
like to me if you do enjoy subscribe for
new visa guys have a great day
you